今37°5分ですというわけでみんな久し
ぶりの熱あんまり僕ねそういうこう熱が出
たり風になることはないんでの辛い状態な
んだよな今37°5部だったんですけど
多分いろんな原因があって今風になって
ます徹夜でレポート書いたのと最近
パズドラにはまっちゃってパズドラの跡
あと基本的に半袖で半ズボ雨で味噌汁食っ
たのも多分原因の1つだと思いますはいと
で今37°5部で結構今追い込まれてるん
ですよでこの状況を打破するために
セブンイレレブンの蒙古断面まこういう
辛い系なんですけどこう風があったり熱が
ある時はな辛いものはやめなきゃいけない
だよ頭痛が悪化したり熱が上がっちゃっ
たりするんですけど俺はなそんな家学に
騙されねえぞこれを食ってこの1回バッて
汗かいて頭も痛くなって熱もマックスまで
行ってそれが引くともう色々吹っ飛ぶと
思うんすよ吹っ飛べばね多分風が治ると
思うん
で吹っ飛ばよ普段ネとが出ないんで
ちょっと結構この辛さが楽しいというか
意外といけてますじゃお湯入れますよし
よしよしよしはい
というわけでしばしを待ち苦しい苦しいの
限界を超えた先にさレジェンドブルーが
待ってると思うのよ極限だからねもう俺今
アルティメット状態だからこの
アルティメット状態でアルティメット辛い
ものうわ色が嘘だろ実は辛いものダメなん
ですよ色がやばい
です
いただき
ます
あいすいませんちょっと取り乱しました
じゃちょっともう1回熱はってみます今の
状態ならね絶対もうね36度5部とかなん
でねぜひ楽しみにしててくださいよ
死ん
[音楽]
だ
イエーイリニアモーターカミュータント
ガールズパぺはどっちから食うどっちから
食うハペはどっちから来るどっちから来る
うんそうね茶色いところああそれ
ドーナッツのと一緒わーミュータント
タートルズ